John how often would you say that a
filmmaker reaches out to you with let's
say five days left in their crowdfunding
campaign and you want to help them so
evening in terms of reaches out in what
way you know like help my campaign
pretty much I get that once a week and I
ignore it you know it's like I don't
know if someone's just saying I ignore
and you know for better anyone who just
says John help me with my crowdfunding
campaign you know to me it's like I
don't have a relationship with you you
know you're reaching out to me when you
just want money or you want my help
getting you money it's like well you
haven't learned anything from any lesson
that I've ever taught you know it's like
why what is the point what is the why
would I engage with you at that point
you know if you want to engage with me
in advance of that in any way shape or
form even to ask me a question on
Twitter and seek my advice on something
or make a joke or somehow involve me as
a person great and then you have a
crowdfunding campaign and you say hey
John could you do this because we have a
relationship sure but I don't even keep
track of how many people say oh promote
my this that or the other thing and I
don't have a relationship with them and
I ignore it and I feel perfectly find
ignoring it because that person hasn't
made the effort to have a relationship
with me it's pretty easy to have a
relationship with me I have to say you
know I'm pretty busy and sometimes it
takes me some days to get back to people
and stuff and you know a but generally
it's rare that I don't within a couple
of weeks respond to everything so you
know with that being said if you haven't
tried then you're not really you know
you're not trying hard enough so is that
are those things that you love to tell
them but either don't have the time or
don't yeah I don't even bother at that
point it's like you know it's like it's
just it's not my job to tell people that
I'm not engaging with them when they're
asked
me to help them make money when they
haven't engaged me beforehand because I
say that all the time to people so you
obviously haven't read my book and so if
you haven't read my book then why are
you asking me to help you so when my
book is so cheap and easily available
you know and even and generally if you
ask me for a free copy generally I'll
give you a free copy so with that being
said it's interesting that you know
people need to remember that you know
that we're in an exchange based economy
or a referral based economy and that you
know if you want to someone to do
something with you you have to provide
them value on some level you know and
I'm not saying that to be selfish or you
know you know demanding or anything like
that but you have to start practicing
those muscles or exercise those muscles
in order to be successful and the other
thing is if you're coming to me for help
in the last five days of your
crowdfunding campaign chances are you're
too late because and this is the thing
about crowdfunding campaigns that people
don't understand the way you structure
your campaign is how your will largely
determine how you're so whether you're
successful or not and that goes in terms
of how much you ask for what your
rewards are what your positioning is
what your call to action is all of that
which is in the structuring of the
campaign will help determine whether
you're successful or not so and that's
why five days before the end of the
campaign is most likely too late for any
kind of help that I can provide you know
or I would want to provide you know
you